this is being called a once in a
generation storm
the threat of heavy snow ice and
dangerously high winds has already
prompted some States to declare a state
of emergency
hey this is really a very serious
weather alert here
and it goes from Oklahoma all the way to
Wyoming and Wyoming to Maine
and it's a real consequence so I
encourage everyone everyone please heed
the local warning
that's the way weather has disrupted
holiday plans for millions of Americans
frustration Norms as thousands of
flights have been canceled
every year we try to spend Christmas or
Thanksgiving or something like that
together just you know to keep the
family connected so it's it's really
important
staying home are breathing for
record-breaking cold temperatures
if you're not bundled up if you don't
have gloves a hat a nice pair of boots
probably some unders some long johns or
whatnot you will be cold the storm is
sweeping through the central United
States and heading east
forecasters worn Millions more will face
harsh weather in the coming days
Matthew capucci is a meteorologist based
in Washington DC Matthew just how bad is
this storm
so this storm is bad for many different
reasons number one it's Obama genetic
Cyclone right bomb Cyclone basically a
storm that's rapidly intensifying to the
point that it Vacuums in air from all
different sides now on the Eastern side
but on the Eastern Seaboard I.E
Washington DC Baltimore Philadelphia New
York Boston those areas are seeing a lot
of rain fall up to about five or six
centimeters and very strong winds in New
England gusting upwards of 90 kilometers
per hour so that's high impact up there
and we'll also see a flash freeze
tomorrow which would cause major issues
in the roadways off the West on the back
side of the system frigid Siberian areas
are wrapping down on the backside with
temperatures falling back to about minus
40 or lower Celsius and again that's
Celsius so very impressive stuff with
wind chills at minus 50 Celsius in
between the two air masses Clash you get
snow and with the Wind of blizzard
conditions so a travel nightmare for the
roughly 110 million Americans have to
travel about 80 kilometers or more this
holiday
how dangerous is it when temperatures
drop that low
well when temperatures get that low it's
the point where the human body can
really function on unless they're inside
a shelter so one of the big piece of
piece of advice we've been giving folks
is that if they're driving have an
emergency kit in the car you simply
can't survive these kind of temperatures
if you're not prepared all it takes is
your vehicle to break down if your
Farmers can't get to you you know things
could become very problematic very
quickly so it's imperative folks have a
way to sort of have a backup plan need
bees that's something we're watching
right now should people be venturing out
at all
ideally known and that's for many
different reasons on the Eastern
Seaboard we briefly alluded to that
flash freeze temperatures will go from
I'd say three or four degrees Celsius
with rainfall to suddenly like three or
four below zero Celsius with ice and so
all the roadways tomorrow will freeze up
up and down the East Coast causing very
dangerous travel farther west when the
temperatures are bitterly low as we talk
about very dangerous to travel and in
between where you're getting snow
visibilities may only be a couple
hundred meters at best so that's
dangerous to drive and of course the Air
Force seeing issues as well Chicago and
Detroit's both the major hubs impacted
by the snowfall up to 2 000 flights
already canceled it'll get worse before
it gets better
our authorities prepared for this would
you say
I I do believe they are so we saw this
coming at least I'd say six or seven
days in advance we knew that over
all storm I think one of the things that
we're wondering about Authority wise is
whether Texas can handle the cold
temperatures back last year in February
they saw dozens of fatalities in the
entire State versus about 4 000
customers about four million rather
customers lost electricity because the
power grid couldn't handle the cold this
time around authorities have kind of
made the tweaks they need to power
companies have done the same thing
they're faring much better this time
Matthew capucci thank you very much
a pleasure